3d movies are they always cool Clash of
the Titans okay so in a world where 50%
of the movies that come out of remakes
anyway I've been waiting for a remake of
Clash of the Titans I just thought it'd
be cool you know to see the Greek
mythology all hardcore and awesome
thrown on the screen and still not be as
cool as God of War just saying honestly
man this movie oh my god I mean let's
start with the characters Sam
Worthington was hollow as hell anyone
could have played him and all he had to
do was just stand there all stoic and
depressed like Kratos is wimpy half
brother second generation twice removed
and that's not only what he did most
it's what he did well Percy's then
embarks on a boring quest to find a way
to kill the great Kraken why does every
movie involving a cracked and suck
Persis is accompanied on his quest by a
group of really cliched warriors I mean
you have the guy that hates his guts but
you just know he's gonna respect him by
the end you have the hot chick props for
the hot chick you have Jar Jar Binks
from transformers 2 in human form who
exists specifically for that really
forced and cliched dialogue and then
halfway through the quest they just go
yeah you know what [ __ ] this is too
tough route 10 they just leave what was
the point of those guys honestly by the
end of this movie you remember like one
guy from his team maybe two it's just
unconscionable the action sequences were
okay all three of them the scorpions
were lame asked or maybe I'm just bitter
because they just dominated the trailer
the medusa scene was the coolest scene
in the movie i'll say that that scene
was really cool it's not worth the
weight or price of admission but it's
really cool and the kraken scene was a
lot better than i thought it would be
but it still makes for a really
anti-climatic climax of the movie as for
the gods i liked seeing them when they
actually showed them then being Hades
and zoos the two that it actually ever
really shows the rest of the gods are
just kind of extras so we're just
painted up standing in the background in
Olympus it was kind of a bait-and-switch
I mean what's the catchphrase for this
movie damn the gods we were promised man
versus gods and what we got were the
stunt doubles from Lord of the Rings
going on their own little quest that
wasn't half as entertaining or one-tenth
is important now one thing I'm just
gonna straight-up [ __ ] about is the 3d
it is every bit as bad as you've heard
it is and
maybe I am some resolution snob maybe
I'm one of those guys who's just like oh
this game is 1080i not 1080p is not
worth it if it's not 1080p I mean 1080i
- I can totally tell if his 1080i
progressive is the only way to play and
not interlace I mean II play in
progressive it's just not worth it it
was not penaity peeves is no it's not hi
David it's not 1080p or and that's my
way of saying this is actually the case
Warner Brothers didn't actually intend
to release this movie in 3d and then 3d
became so huge because of avatar and
then they rushed the production of the
3d in this movie so they can cash out in
the latest 3d craze and as a result the
3d it looks like [ __ ] like there's
this coffin that just looks like flat
and cardboard like when it's supposed to
be round like a coffin and imagine 3d
where something's supposed to be in the
foreground but it's in the background
it's really weird it looks horrible and
they did it to get five more bucks out
of each of you per ticket I mean a lot
of stuffs been coming out in 3d lately
and I've been really leaning on it
because I really like 3d I think it's a
really genuinely cool step of immersion
for entertainment for people but this is
just some cash out [ __ ] so if you
insist on watching this movie and being
disappointed at least watch it in 2d if
for nothing else you'll save a few bucks
so forgettable characters boring plot
[ __ ] dialogue and really cheesy cheap
boring and corny ass ending just drive
me to tell you to skip this [ __ ] but for
some free entertainment click on my link
in the sidebar to see more
yeah there's no Medusa but there's also
not 15 irrelevant characters and shitty
3d
[Music]